this is yet another way right Vanessa
that all garden is trying to not just
attach themselves so Millennials but but
getting onto this whole crowd sourcing
customization movement right yeah
exactly i mean this is a great way for a
brand to engage with their customers of
course but it may also during voting so
you vote online for whether you want to
be part of all gardens team north or its
teams out but in order to place your
vote you have to give them your email
address oh so it's a great way for a
marketer to stay in touch with their
fans as well and who's winning by the
way do we know so far team north is
winning oh okay I guess America is not
ready for peperoncino so northern
cuisine is winning out that's good to
know but you know this is also another
way right where all of garden is trying
to reverse the sales declines that
they've seen at their store other
restaurants right that's right um Olive
Garden's same-store sales have been
falling for the last five quarters they
tried to ensure investors that things
were okay by reporting a point six
percent increase for the month of
September however as we all know their
board was replaced poll numbers yes
right darlings our code that was just so
crazy to hear even in the activist world
but you know but this whole idea of like
of just you know we're going to provide
you as many varieties as possible we're
going to give you you know rely do
customized I mean we've got the the
pizza hut CEO on in the next hour where
they're touting two billion ways to make
your pizza now I told people that around
the newsroom and everyone's like I don't
want that I just want plain I'm sorry so
is that really I mean is that how people
how restaurants are gonna attract people
yeah I can think of maybe like two
pizzas that I know or they're mostly
exactly but they do so I'm today Pizza
Hut unveils its new menu okay and it has
new ingredients they have a bunch of new
crusts like a reef flavored curry
flavored crust pretzel crust they've got
some new sauces like honey sriracha you
can also put a drizzle on your pizza
also honey sriracha right and it's a
more variety they think means younger
people into their stores into their
restaurants right i mean this is all
about
trying bold new flavors giving people
more options that's McDonald's CEO put
it people want more choices in terms of
how they order what they order and how
they're served so I think we're going to
see a lot of this kind of customization
trend in fast food as you know they're
trying to lure the Millennial customer I
don't I don't know if these types of
marketing tactics are as effective with
older consumers well I guess we're all
old here because we're all I go we just
want playing that's all we want all
right Vanessa thank you so much
Bloomberg Businessweek Vanessa wall